I hope you guys are ready for this from
American Military news report Hamas
calls for Global Jihad invasion of
Israel and attacks on Jews worldwide on
October 13th American Military news is
News Guard certified 100 out of 100 if
that means anything to you and they say
a leading and founding member of Hamas
Khaled mhal reportedly called for a
global Jihad on Tuesday asking Muslims
around the world to Target people of
Israel on Friday October 13th video of
Michelle's reported called to violence
was posted on YouTube and remains up on
the platform as of Wednesday at 10: a.m.
according to a translation an analysis
of the video by author brother Rashid
Marshall referred to his proposed day of
anger as the Friday of the al- AXA flood
which will send a message of Rage to the
zionists and to
America okay so you know I'm kind of
worried well that's they show their
numbers they showed their numbers this
week how many are in this country yeah
should we talk about our sweet sweet
border policy yeah and well how many how
many do we know how much how many Hamas
individuals are in the United States no
no I was thinking with the rallies with
the people who are no we saw you know
that there are plenty of people out
there that are are happy to commit VES
uh so I live in New York City so that's
obviously a prime target if people want
to do this so under our last mayor and I
doubt that the current one mayor
nightlife has changed this uh and I
talked to Cops about this actually for
my last book the entire NYPD
anti-terrorism unit was directed to only
focus on white supremacy Lone Wolf white
supremacist terrorist under DeBlasio and
I'm sure it's probably still the same
and uh even cops I was talking to the
time were like
yeah it doesn't exist like they're
mythical creatures there's no white
supremacist terrorist in New York City
this one cop I spoke to was saying they
send the nyp terrorism unit to go train
with the FBI and even the FBI guys were
like yeah no it's Islam this was a
couple years ago like don't listen to
what they're teaching you but still they
took all resources away from Islam even
though since 911 there have been
something like a dozen either successful
or thored terrorist attacks in New York
City MH so is the NYPD prepared I mean
what I haven't heard I don't think so
mayor nightlife say anything about the
anti-terrorism unit and what they're
doing I don't I I I don't think it's
it's just going to be New York I mean
New York's a big Target but yeah this is
the concern look Kevin McCarthy and
Ronda Sanders both pointed this out you
know whether you like any of them or not
okay our our Southern border is so
extremely porous and we know that
several hundred every year and now more
it's it's gone substantially higher are
on the terror watch list I don't know if
you if you want to trust this stuff or
trust our Intel agencies or any of this
I'm just saying like our border is open
okay and there are people coming through
who are not from South America they are
people from China coming through no no
joke there are people from Africa coming
through and of course there are people
from the Middle East coming through so
if Hamas is trying to come bring in
sleeper cells they've been they've been
able to do it for some time under the
Biden Administration when they then say
we're going to send a message to Israel
and the United States I have concerns
about what that may be and it's the one
time I hope the uh uh uh you know our
law enforcement can do a good job of
something instead of just framing you
know rednecks for trying to kidnap
people I always hope they can do a good
job but they just don't always do a good
job I mean the the Border crisis is
something that has been an open issue
and we know that other countries are not
going to say oh well America seems to be
struggling to work this issue out so
we'll just let them we won't send
anybody we're not going to take
advantage of it uh we have no idea
what's what's in this what what the
issues we have wrought for our country
are because we have left our border so
poorest for so long and the Biden
Administration did nothing to stop this
so should hopefully you know
everything's fine on Friday hopefully
nothing happens but if anything happens
we should look directly to the Biden
Administration oh did you see the the
Air Canada pilot that was he got
fired he was just posting what was he
posting signs in support of
Palestine Pro palese and like people
were saying like he was so radical in
his speech they were saying Jewish
people should feel scared to fly with
him and he was put on leave and then
I'll send that's the thing because you
can be Pro Palestine and
pro-israel I want you can I want
coexistence I know I understand the
violence has gotten to a point where the
vengeance is on people's minds but that
doesn't mean you can't support their
both of their rights and and divine
interventions to survive there there
there are uh Arab Arab Israelis that
live in
Israel so Ian the issue seems to be more
so religious and and I get the vi it's
not I was talking to Serge about this
before the shows he made a claim that it
was oh I I mentioned this that it was
about Zionism and he didn't really
mention Judaism and wicked Christians
not not Christians themselves uh ones
that purport to be Christian and like
people Zionism is the idea of creating
an Israeli State a political state in
that area of the world has nothing to do
with the religion I mean you could argue
then that Israelis is all Jews are from
Israel you know judah's father was Jacob
Israel so they're all descended from
Israel but that doesn't mean that every
Israeli is Jewish because Israel had a
lot of sons so there's a lot of um
Orthodox hidic Jew I don't know if
they're actually hiic they they look
aiic and I've seen them protesting in
New York before that are really
anti-israel like they're super against
the Israeli State yeah for religious
reasons I don't believe that it's I
can't get into the exact theology but
mhm uh yeah there's a lot of sances I
mean you can be Pro Palestine you can be
pro Israel you can be pro-jewish you can
be anti-jewish so there's a lot of
things that are going into this not just
like as simple as like that's that's
what Ryan long jokes about it's not just
one side other thing he says i' I've had
all the stances it's like there's not as
it's not as simple as that with this I'm
Pro Abraham yo and Abraham spoke to God
that dude was legit and he had an
awesome family his kids were badasses
and they spawn great tribes of people so
if we can stay focused on that guy I we
have something in common everybody wants
control over the Holy Land yeah that's
where it's been over thousands of years
read the uh forward.com wrote about the
red heer yeah and so apparently
beginning of September there there I'll
give you a really quick simple version
because I don't want to talk too much
about it but the general idea is that
this is a symbol of like the pro the
Messianic era returning or something
like that yeah and so it's just
Christians and and Jews tend to be
aligned in a lot of ways as to what they
expect to happen and what they want to
happen and so that's why there's
coexistence whereas Islam is more so at
odds which is a large portion of the
conflict I was listening to the Quran
last night I've been doing like 30
minutes of it at night or something like
that and they were talking about uh
Ishmael who was son of Abraham and he's
descended from ishmail come the tribe of
of Islam but he's like hanging out with
his dad and they're just talking and I
started to feel like I was there with
them it was wild man like you start to
feel like you're part of that tribe when
you listen to the stories and I I
imagine it's the same with his brother
with Isaac I haven't listened to a lot
of what Isaac did with his dad but like
I understand the pride of being related
to that and to to know and to be able to
track back your Dynasty to the people
because those dudes were like for
whatever reason I don't know if it was
like the strain of the environment that
for that made them listen to God like
under great tension you have no other
choice you start to hear it or like if
you if you're starving you know then
there's better chance you're going to
hear it because you're not clouded what
should regular people do right
don't panic but are people paying
attention to this stuff I'm worried
about what what could or may happen I
think Israel is going to be on high
alert obviously and this could this
could be this this statement this guy
put out is escalation and that's just
bad yeah outright but if there's already
ongoing attacks there's already rocket
attacks if something happens in the
United States
man I don't want to see the US get
involved in another you know conflict
but it looks like that's where we're
going right with Special Special
Operations being offer it up to Israel
and uh you've already got a bunch of
politicians calling for direct support
more funding more aid but and war with
Iran right Yep this is making me think
of Putin he made a statement and it's
there's a video of it Jackson Hingle
tweeted it out and he's basically saying
if men decide to fight Let Them Fight
leave the women and children alone he's
like in he's in a bad place right now
and I'm not the greatest guy Earth even
Putin standing with is you can't do this
we wanted some land let's like go easy
not that he he didn't make life good for
the ukrainians the last few years but
you could say that maybe other people
were involved in I think it's morale
crushing I think no matter no matter who
you are as a leader like let's there's
let's say there's the Red Faction and
the blue faction and they're at
War everyone as human beings have
similar desires and understandings and
despises seeing women and children
killed this is not every person but of
of civilized countries like obviously
we're at odds with Russia and China but
you will de moralize your Fighters if
you're actively saying go out there and
kill kids they're going to be like man I
don't want to fight anymore like it's
just you're not fighting for anything
you can you can recognize yep yeah they
gota they got to trick themselves into
thinking that the enemy is like a rat is
like
not but even then targeting children is
going to be extremely difficult it's
kind of like a Rat's Nest like you don't
you don't spare the baby rats you just
take it out right but my point is in a
civilized country in like a modern
developed Nation I should say not don't
necessarily mean civilized I don't know
but in like Russia for instance if if if
if he goes to if Putin goes to his
troops and says yes what happened in
Israel haha we're we're for it he's
going to demoralize his men yeah I don't
think Russia's the bad guy they've been
made out to be it's like the reason why
we have these like war crimes and these
laws is because we're kind of like dude
we might fight but you know leave the
kids out of it and then we we have that
hope that the other the other faction
May respect not killing the children but
then you know one of the things we've
learned consistently the Middle East is
uh kids are not spared M I was talking
to uh some dudes a while ago in the Army
who had been deployed and they said the
scary thing is imagine you're you're
you're in a convoy you're in a truck and
you're delivering supplies and then all
of a sudden a little kid walks out into
the middle of the road what do you do
got to shoot him in the military in
there the kid has strapped a bomb to his
chest exactly and the kid could have a
bomb you don't what do you do I'm like
you don't know you don't know I don't
know don't have the answers it's like
that's the difficult thing you're
dealing with when you're when you're
over there is they will use children yep
yeah they did in Vietnam too I mean it's
probably an act of desperation you know
when the vietn the Vietnamese they were
living underground because the carpet
bombs were so intense so they would send
kids walking into camp with a basket I
think desperation so much as uh
determination to win at all costs I
think they are willing to sacrifice for
that I mean that is something that they
if if you believe your causes is the
most important thing you could ever
achieve in your life then what is the
bar where is the line why wouldn't you
send children to it because then they
are ultimately serving this great cause
I just got a little Cassandra just uh
hit me up that the Biden White House has
walked back the baby comment really uh
this is tweeted out from yeah we're GNA
have to look at Evan Hill at Evan Hill
clarification from the White House
regarding Biden's remarks I've been
doing this a long time Biden said of the
White House I never thought I'd see
maybe I never really thought I would see
oh man I see this is why I say you got
to be skeptical don't trust Joe Biden
Washington Post has the story what yeah
that's amazing let me uh where where
what what is this it just jumped Let's
uh let's say uh
Biden uh no where's where's like he's
got a screenshot here clarification of
the White House recing B Marks uh a
White House spokesperson later clarified
that us officials in the president have
not seen pictures or confirmed reports
independently the president bases
comments about the alleged atrocities on
the claims from netanyahu's spokesman
and media reports from Israel according
to the White House but he said he saw
them and that he confirmed that they
were real yes saw confirmed and then
when you click the
link I never really thought that I would
see and have
confirmed pictures of
terrorists beheading
children I never thought i' hey we all
knew Joe Biden was a scum but wait he
didn't say he did he just said I never
thought I would I never thought I would
see have confirmed pictures of
terrorists maybe he's more clever than
we
thought he read script weasel words
assumptive language where you're right
he didn't say he saw it yeah he said he
never thought he would and he didn't so
he's good but the implication is of
course that you did see it say I never
thought I would especially with his big
emotional pause like he's so overcome by
his emotion can't finish his sentence
yeah when I go to the Washington Post
link I just get in a dead link it's not
taking me to the story did they delete
the story I think they're updating it is
updating but I'm not seeing what he what
he what this guy screen grabed is not
appearing on Washington
Post Washington Post has now removed it
cu the White House has to walk back
their walk back jeez what's real man
this could be a fake a fake debunking
right yeah who knows but he never said
that he saw it that that clip does not
appear in the article so this screenshot
from Evan Hill who is a Washington Post
Visual and forensic investigations at wo
whatever this link is is not what he
posted so I don't know where where this
is coming
from so I don't know man no idea yeah
well let's stay stand on Biden's words
he never thought he would see it and
that's all he said so as far as I know
he never saw it he never claimed to have
seen it he never thought he would
confirm that I have no information he
never said that he did confirm it it's
that not good though that the leader of
our country is being so ambiguous in his
speech in a way that potentially be seen
as inflammatory and calling for more
intervention on the US like it's not
okay that it's not clear time when we
need Clarity he is supposed to offer
this to the American people and he's not
yeah he just wants to be on on the right
side of History you know so just like
Ryan long he doesn't really know what
statement he's supposed to put up yet
he's waiting to hear all I can say is
right now this tweet from the Evan H
from Evan Hill The Washington Post I'm
not seeing corroborated anywhere else in
fact all of the most recent stories from
the past few minutes just show Biden's
quotes of him saying implying that he
had seen it so that Washington Post link
is dead so I don't know what he's
posting hm
so I I I assume it is this is what I was
saying I'm skeptical I'm not about to
start trusting Joe Biden right there you
go wow did they run it as if he said
that he saw they ran the article that we
read earlier with the oh dude look at
this NBC uh was it NBC News Biden he saw
saw he said that he could he couldn't he
didn't think he ever would that's all he
said I never really thought that I would
see and have confirmed pictures of
terrorist beheading
children all he look if you want to get
line you would never say un you didn't
want people to think that you did see it
I think I think for actually ver I think
to verify what he said You' need the the
two minutes leading up to I never
thought I would see a video of Joe Biden
mercilessly beating a child I never
thought I would confirm it either yeah I
never thought I would confirm it yeah
you can't sue me Joe I never said I saw
a video of it you said you never thought
you see exactly yeah oh jeez oh my god
wow this is the beginning man this is
like this is the future of warfare is
your mind future man if they can get you
to turn on your to turn on your
neighbors like that's how that's the
best way to win is curve infow Wars info
wars definitely man it's weird these are
wild times man thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next
time